bonsoir monsieur données merci d'être
avec nous tout d'abord en est un
politicien mais quand même votre avis
sur cette question on voit que le bras
de fer ce temps avec la convocation de
l'ambassadrice française
ça vous inquiète que ça tourne ainsi à
la crise diplomatique ont finalement
autant crever l'abcès et allons-y pour
les négociations
je crois qu'il est temps de crever
l'abcès nous sommes dans l'attenté
l'incertitude uniquement pour la
question des accès dans les eaux
britanniques et jersiaise égard de
sièges on attend ça depuis maintenant
onze mois et il est temps effectivement
de
crever cet abcès bourre après on sait
très bien que de la gesticulation de
part et d'autre chacun montre tout de
suite ses muscles je pense pas que ça
finira en en bataille navale entre les
britanniques et les français nous sommes
tout à fait conscients que le poids
économique dans les deux pays d'ailleurs
est assez est assez petit par contre
c'est clair comme nous sommes des
symboles et c'est clair aussi que
quelque part on représente la façon dont
l'accord du bric site sera appliquée sur
l'ensemble des secteurs en tout cas la
france a brandi des menaces elle a
montré ses muscles
elle a une raison selon vous justement
d'utiliser deux de ces mesures de
rétention ces menaces en tout cas
alors les les menaces ou les mesures de
commandes hier de mauvaise humeur pour
reprendre l'expression
de la ministre
samedi dernier c'est oui c'était
peut-être un peu nécessaire pour faire
avancer les choses cela fait concernant
les britanniques donc le sud angleterre
qu'en fait il ya deux façades il ya bien
la façade sud anglaise et la façade des
îles anglo normandes
concernant la le sud angleterre ça fait
des mois maintenant que les discussions
se sont enlisés et pendant longtemps le
royaume uni n'a pas répondu aux demandes
de l'europe sur qu'est-ce qu'un avis
remplaçant sans rentrer dans le détail
qui est d'une complexité technique
absolument ahurissante en gros il ya des
bateaux qui ont pu prouver qu'ils
étaient dans les eaux anglaises de 2012
2016 par des moyens notamment de
repérage sa télé mais entre 2016 et 2020
la vie s'est poursuivie certains ou
acheter ou ont fait construire des
bateaux et ils se retrouvent sans droits
mais alors qu'ils pratiquaient ces eaux
par le passé et leur seule façon de
rentrer et de faire un moment donné un
bilan en dix ans entre 2012 et 2016 il
est temps de bateaux y en a tant qui
sont restés à nathan qui sont sortis et
bien remplaçons ceux qui sont sortis et
on
rentre dans un dialogue de sourd depuis
mon nom a depuis le début de l'année
alors que la solution pourrait être
assez facilement trouver même si on sait
qu'un des négociations ça pourrait être
assez facilement trou et
pêcheurs sentiment d'être pris en otage
certains notamment à boulogne-sur-mer
estime avoir perdu jusqu'à la moitié de
leur exploitation depuis le mois d'avril
comment se traduit ce manque à gagner
d'une peur nous avons été accompagnés
par l'europe en ce qui concerne les
aides à l'arrêt pendant
plus qu'à quatre à cinq semaines voire
une deuxième salve pour ceux notamment
qui pouvait justifier d'un dommage et
d'une longue période
de fréquentation des eaux britanniques
donc ça il ya quelque part un remède de
provisoire aurait des no no no float
histoire est différente face à d' autres
france normandie et bretagne mais les
pêcheurs d'abord n'ont pas envie de
vivre subventions ils veulent vivre de
leur travail et on sait très bien que ça
ne peut être qu'une solution tout à fait
tout à fait provisoire donc oui certains
ont perdu
alors une partie de leur chiffre
d'affaires partiellement compensée
d'autres perdre en perdant en qualité en
rendement de production notamment ceux
qui vont se réfugier dans l'es6 12000
anglais la bande côtière quand il fait
mauvais temps et d'autres côtés
notamment aux us cotton teinte ne
peuvent plus accéder à certains
n'acceptent de son qui seront encore
plus nombreux à compter du 30 octobre et
c'est cela en fait qu'ils sont en
situation vraiment critique alors pour
le député ministre de jersey relais les
pêcheurs français n'obtiennent pas
naissance tout simplement parce que je
cite il n'envoie pas les preuves que ces
navires pêchaient déjà dans les eaux
britanniques avant le le break site
alors on sait que c'est extrêmement
complexe d'apporter ses preuves
alors je crois tout d'abord que on
souffre notamment avec les îles anglo
normandes jersey et guernesey du fait
que tout ça transitent par bruxelles et
par londres 1 ça fait des circuits
administratifs extrêmement long
manifestement toutes les informations
quand elles partent ne pas des régions
ou de paris n'arrive pas complètement
non plus à jersey donc ça veut dire qu'à
un moment donné il ya de la perte en
ligne donc ça c'est assez
incompréhensible mais ça semble être une
réalité donc dans l'ancien traité dit
bertrand ville qui était une quelque
chose un peu critiquable c'est sûr mais
tu fonctionner finalement
on avait deux à trois réunions par an
normand-breton janvier pour avoir un
dialogue direct et ça c'était bien donc
ça ça permettrait déjà de mettre de
l'huile dans le dans le tuyau juillet et
puis aussi sur tout de suite les
difficultés ça concerne des bateaux de
moins de 12 mètres qui n'ont pas de
moyens satellite à bonn il n'était pas
obligé puisque certains sont tout
simplement une barre de 7 ou 8 mai avec
juste une petite cabine pour protéger un
homme et
les donc toutes les données étaient
saisis sur des papiers et parfois sur
des zones de pêche quand vous mettez la
zone de pêche elle peut être tantôt
jersiaise tantôt française et descendre
plus bas dans le détail est extrêmement
compliqué d'autres ont seront saisis
s'assurent leur informatique mais depuis
le temps alors on a des cas où le pc
tout simplement pris l'eau est
inutilisable et donc qui est comme ça
des pertes en ligne qui se font donc un
minimum de bienveillance aurait sur
certains vendent aussi on voit des
dossiers sont bloqués parce qu'ils
apportent la preuve pour dix jours et
non pas onze jours bon très clairement
partie au moment où un bateau et à dix
jours
merci beaucoup en tout cas marca de là
et d'avoir apporté votre
voir plus clair sur ce dossier assez
complet c'est effectivement